in the earlier videos from this week as
well as from the videos from the past
several weeks you've already seen the
basic building blocks of board
propagation and back propagation the key
components you need to implement a deep
neural network let's see how you can put
these components together to build your
deep net use the network with a few
layers let's pick one layer and look at
the computations focusing on just that
layer for now so for layer L you have
some parameters WL and Bo and for the
forward prop you will input the
activations a L minus 1 from the
previous layer and output Al so the way
we did this previously was you compute Z
l equals WL x al minus 1 plus BL um and
then al equals G of ZL right so that's
how you go from the input al minus 1 to
the output al and it turns out that for
later use will be useful to also cache
the value ZL so let me include this on
cache as well because storing the value
ZL will be useful for backward for the
back propagation step later and then for
the backward step or 3 for the back
propagation step again focusing on
computation for this layer L you're
going to implement a function that
inputs da of L and output da L minus 1
and just the special the details the
input is actually da FL as well as the
cache so you have available to you the
value of ZL that you compute it and
in addition to outputting GL minus 1 you
will output the gradients you want in
order to implement gradient descent for
learning okay so this is the basic
structure of how you implement this
forward step I'm going to call the
forward function as well as this
backward step using a callback wave
function so just to summarize in layer L
you're going to have you know the
forward step or the forward property'
forward function input 800 minus 1 and
output Al and in order to make this
computation you need to use wo and BL um
and also output a cache which contains
ZL and then on the backward function
using the back prop step will be another
function then now inputs the AFL and
outputs da l minus 1 so it tells you
given the derivatives respect to these
activations that's da FL how what are
the derivatives or how much do I wish
you know al minus 1 changes to compute
the derivatives respect to the
activations from the previous layer
within this box ready need to use WL and
BL and it turns out along the way you
end up computing VL and then this false
this backward function can also output
dwl and DB l but now sometimes using red
arrows to denote the backward elevation
so if you prefer we could draw these
arrows in red so if you can implement
these two functions then the basic
computation of the neural network will
be as follows you're going to take the
input features a zero see that in and
that will compute the activations of the
first layer let's call that a 1 and to
do that you needed W 1 and B 1 and then
we'll also you know cache
away v1 now having done that you feed
that this is the second layer and then
using W 2 and B 2 you're going to
compute the activations our next layer a
2 and so on until eventually you end up
outputting a capital L which is equal to
Y hat and along the way we cashed all of
these on values Z so that's the forward
propagation step now for the back
propagation step what we're going to do
will be a backward sequence of
iterations in which you're going
backwards and computing gradients like
so so as you're going to feed in here da
L and then this box will give us da L
minus 1 and so on until we get da - da 1
you could actually get one more output
to compute da 0 but this is derivative
respect your input features which is not
useful at least for training the weights
of these are supervised neural networks
so you could just stop it there belong
the way back prop also ends up
outputting PWL DB l right this used
times with wo and BL this would output d
w3 t p3 and so on so you end up
computing all the derivatives you need
and so just a maybe so in the structure
of this a little bit more right these
boxes will use those parameters as well
wo PL and it turns out that we'll see
later that inside these boxes we'll end
up computing disease as well so one
iteration of training for a new network
involves starting with a zero which is X
and going through for profit as follows
computing y hats and then using that to
compute this and then back prop right
doing that and now you have all these
derivative terms and so you know W will
get updated as some W minus the learning
rate times DW right for each of the
layers and similarly for B right now
we've compute the back prop and have all
these derivatives so that's one
iteration of gradient descent for your
neural network now before moving on just
one more implementational detail
conceptually will be useful to think of
the cashier as storing the value of Z
for the backward functions but when you
implement this you see this in the
programming exercise when you implement
it you find that the cash may be a
convenient way to get this value of the
parameters at W 1 V 1 into the backward
function as well so the program exercise
you actually spawn the cash is Z as well
as W and B all right so to store z2w to
be 2 but from an implementational
standpoint i just find this a convenient
way to just get the parameters copied to
where you need to need to use them later
when you're computing back propagation
so that's just an implementational
detail that you see when you do the
programming exercise so you've now seen
one of the basic building blocks for
implementing the deep neural network in
each layer there's a for propagation
step and there's a corresponding
backward propagation step and there's a
cash deposit information from one to the
other
in the next video we'll talk about how
you can actually implement these
building blocks let's go on to the next
video